it was European Commission President
jean-claude yonkers fourth and last
State of the Union address at the
European Parliament collection of the
linear portion is what I call moment
where they will concede albeit with
eight months before the European
elections the debate was an opportunity
to sketch an ambitious path for the
future of the EU of 27 into the same
preview war Adela democracy thank you
for the initiatives to make our European
elections safe not trolls not fake news
not Cambridge analytics will decide the
people I want to answer the Commission
in the coming months would introduce a
package of proposals to protect our
elections against foreign meddling
Janka stressed the need for unity in the
face of rising populism said colleague
Sean Cooney who some prefer a less as
men discover deal capacity the union
members looked back on yonkers
achievements and called for action on
migration climate change and the economy
it's a scandal what we witnessed again
in this summer in the Mediterranean
climate change is happening it's
happening now and the good news about
climate change is that we know what to
do and the bad news about climate change
is that we don't do it yeah we're
missing a flesh tone that's often Yavin
off begin the finance creaser that's
bullsh dance move or Austin for kite
please and time and fuel and an Amish
militarized police others touched upon
the current divisions in Europe the
number of people who are dissatisfied
deeply dissatisfied with the European
project is increasing you made no
acknowledgement for the populist revolt
that is sweeping through virtually every
single member stated that universal
commission anatella far back
anti-democratic affinity Janka stressed
the need to turn Europe into a greater
global player on the world stage
protecting the Union for the
nations to come
[Music]